I was excited to do it I'm always
excited to do stupid [ __ ] because I'm
stupid
hey I'm go out there 4000 and this is
dissector play uh Drake is a good friend
of mine yeah we met the Instagram I got
a new song out called flossing and the
video is really controversial in Wilde
and I wanted Drake to talk about it
so I wagered with him on the game cuz
I'm from the bay and I obviously go hard
for the Warriors like as this year been
going hard for the rapid I'm not as rich
as Audrey so I didn't want to bet no
money with that maybe in and then um I
proposed that if I win he would have to
post the video on his Instagram feed
story and tweeted he agreed if I was to
stand in the Bay Bridge where the sign
that says Kauai and drag to beat the bay
and I just in order to get him to do it
I was like and I'll be in a raptor suit
because I could never control my mouth
making the bet I knew I was gonna win it
was not there was no doubt in my heart
so then I just make the bed and me and
my heart loss people start reading the
sign and you could just feel the drivers
getting angrier and angrier and then one
dude even noticed me and drove by he's
like what dad you hurt me you hurt me
walk back and I told him I what I had to